You're an interesting man Scott Lang
you're an Avenger
you have a daughter but you've
lost a lot of time like me
we could help each other with that
who are you I'm the man who can give you
the one thing you want what's that time
he can rewrite existence and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care
who this guy is I just lost so much
he can give us a second chance
let me make this easy for you he will bring me
what I need or everything you call a life will end
this is all my fault
you may not want her to watch this we had a deal
you thought you could win
I don't have to win.
We both just have to lose.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my new Ant-Man in the Wasp Quantumania trailer
video there's a whole bunch of new footage we
see way more Kang the Conqueror so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos because
obviously this is meant to set up Avengers 5
Kang Dynasty pretty much all the dialogue or
most of the dialogue in the trailer takes place
in that conversation that we saw bits of in the
last trailer where Scott Lang is meeting Kang for
the first time and he's kind of lying to him but
then kind of revealing who he is he's trying to
convince scottline to help him steal something
that will help him complete his time platform that
he can't just get himself because the whole idea
is that he's stuck in the quantum realm otherwise
he would have escaped a long time ago he needs
something that only Scott Lang can steal probably
because if he tries to steal it then he'll wind up
dying and he doesn't want that in order to do that
he holds Cassie Lang hostage obviously you see her
in her Stinger gear we see a bunch of Kang in his
full-on comic book uniform you see him take off
and then put on the blue mask and the way they're
explaining the blue face from the comics is that
it is just part of his mask but you notice when
his mask goes away briefly like he takes his mask
off his eyes stay blue briefly and it's the same
blue energy that he's giving off in Blast when
he's shooting Ant-Man when he's in his full comic
book costume they're a couple different types of
portals that you see the whole idea is that his
technology is based on Quantum energy just like
the tva's portals because he created the TVA it's
the same technology that Pym particles are made
of that they use in Avengers end game to do their
Big Time Heist but it sounds like Ant-Man figures
out pretty quickly what's going on with him and
then he just flat out tells him unless you help me
I will basically end all of your existence would
Janet Van Dyne sort of tying things to larger's
Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty in the Loki series with
the timelines talk he can change the timeline
he can change existence basically by altering
the past and the future he can erase timelines
talking about more timelines from the Loki series
just starting with the footage at the beginning of
the trailer when they get out of the car there's
a celebration here on the red carpet is because
when the events of the movie pick up hope van
Dyna started to use Pym particles to cure world
hunger like she's growing food literally larger to
cure world hunger and they're celebrating that he
specifically references The Avengers because
Ant-Man tries to make himself seem real big
like I'm an Avenger you should watch out for me
but the whole joke being is that part of Kang's
dialogue is oh you're an Avenger have I killed
you before because the whole idea is that during
the Kane Multiverse War he faced many versions of
the Avengers and killed all of them this is just
a scene of Scott Lang falling into the quantum
realm and Landing for the first time it seems
like when Kang starts talking about losing time
he's referencing the time that he's lost because
he's been stuck in the quantum realm and time
moves there differently so he's been stuck there
for a long time but the whole idea is that Scott
Lang lost five plus years that he was stuck in the
quantum realm that's why he whips out his phone
he has the picture of the young Cassie laying
on it because he basically missed Cassie growing
up he picks her up at the police station because
she's been getting in trouble she's a chip off
the old block she wants to become a scientist
just like he is he's an engineer if he didn't
realize that they just use him for comedy in
most of the movies so you don't really pick up on
that sometimes since Avengers endgame she's been
reading through a lot of Hank pym's journals in
all of their scientific journals and that's how
she created the quantum signaling device that
alerts Kang to their presence and allows him
to pull them into the quantum realm Kang is the
person who pulls them in when she turns on the
beacon and like I said as he starts talking to
him Kang starts to appeal to him like look I can
help give you more time and it sounds like for
just a hot second Ant-Man considers helping him
in order to get that time back quote unquote but
the whole idea is that you never trust villains in
the Marvel Universe they're never going to do what
they say they're going to do we see him with the
mask on you see the blue face and they show you
that it is Just Energy we see a much bigger shot
of what seems like his version of chronopolis
down in the quantum realm I think that they're
going to say that this is a version of comic
book chronopolis they kind of use the TVA in
the same way during the Loki series chronopolis is
basically like the city that he rules over when he
is the immortus version of his character that's
like him at the end of his timeline so obviously
they're mixing and matching a lot of things
from different parts of Kang's storyline in
the comics when Janet Van Dyne starts making all
the Loki Easter eggs The Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
Secret Wars Easter eggs about Kang changing all
of reality changing time erasing timelines you
see what looks like a portal reaching out of the
quantum realm like he's building this giant device
in the entire device is like a huge Transformer
his entire time platform that will help him win
the Kang Multiverse war and it just sounds like
this Kang variant wants to use the quantum realm
and all the other variants of Kang that are vying
for control in the Kang Multiverse war or trying
different methods there's been rumors that in
Avengers Secret Wars we're going to see a version
of the beyonder that's another Kang variant
wielding different types of power because the
beyonders are extra dimensional beings the power
that they wield is completely different one of the
other big things too is when you see the Rings
come up you see the etchings like the carvings
and the markings on the Rings they look just like
the markings on shangshi's 10 rings and just like
the markings on Ms Marvel's bands so Kang might
have been the person who created the 10 Rings any
might have created both of Miss Marvel's Bengals
when they start talking about timelines you see
the multiple versions of Ant-Man later you see a
big pile of them like this is an army of ant men
reaching one of them up onto the platform here
I guess you could think of them as variants but
they might not be full-blown variants but we've
been making jokes about how Ant-Man is going to
die in this movie this would be how they wind
up killing a whole bunch of them we see another
portal in this same Red Energy area it looks like
the wreckage of one of Kang's older ships or some
other place where he takes Ant-Man to go steal
something for him the beings behind him that
are escorting Cassie Lang with the blue mask on
like Kang's mask or just members of his army the
other big thing you'll notice here zoom in hands
we finally see a version of Modoc MCU Modoc is
actually just Darren Cross he's been transformed
into Modoc somehow because they're with Kang here
maybe Kang is the person that turned him into
Modoc I believe during the movie He's supposed to
be both a villain and wind up helping them as well
and I don't think that he dies at the end of the
movie I think he escapes and winds up in future
Marvel movies you can let me know what you think
the special energy is that they're looking at this
red energy but it seems like this is something
that Kang wants for his device Ant-Man looks like
he's diving into some area to get whatever it is
that Kang needs and this is giant organism that's
just part of the quantum realm this is just one
of the organisms down the quantum realm that it
seems like Janet Van Dyne uses so they can get
around like she's lived there for so long she
knows way more about the quantum realm than any
of the others there's a lot of life forms that are
either stuck down there or evolved down there and
are just naturally members of their races that
live there like I said this scene makes it seem
like these bands are the exact same as shangshi's
10 rings in Miss Marvel's bands or at least have
the same markings on them so that might be where
the signal was coming from in the shangshi post
credit scene the signal was acting as a beacon
into the quantum realm back to Kang because the
pattern of the energy here looks like the pattern
of the energy when they zoom in enhanced on the 10
Rings it looks like Ant-Man is using the army of
his copies here to try and destroy this so that
Kane can't win this just seems like another
one of Kang's portals then they have the tag
scene where they say prepare for a new Dynasty
that's obviously a reference to Avengers 5 Kane
Dynasty in this Army will be one of the ones that
they face during that movie like the whole idea I
think is that Kang winds up escaping at the end
of this movie and they face him later during
Marvel Phase 6 and Avengers 5. the way that one of
these Ant-Man copies dies turning to Ribbons kind
of reminds you of Dr Strange Multiverse of Madness
with Scarlet Witch taking out Mr Fantastic turning
him into spaghetti basically it looks like he
winds up having an old-fashioned knock down
drag out fight with Kang and Cassie Lang standing
there watching them they have a full-blown fight
with his comic book uniform on he starts blasting
him with his blue energy this is just a much wider
shot of his time platform slash chronopolis like
I think the entire structure here is both a city
to his army but also the entire thing is his time
travel platform and just like we see an army of
Ant-Man versions this is an army of wasp versions
like there's an army of wasps behind her when
he says I didn't have to win he just had to make
sure that they both lose I think the idea is he's
trying to sacrifice himself and also kill Kang in
the process but obviously I don't think they're
going to kill off Ant-Man during this movie for
good they're just going to make it seem like he
dies with the idea that Kang also does not wind
up dying love the shot that they end onto with
him blasting the frame with blue energy with his
mask on like full-on comic book Kang the Conqueror
obviously there's a whole bunch going on in this
footage so I'll do a couple more Ant-Man videos
this week but if you spotted anything in the
trailers that it didn't talk about in the video
just write them Below in the comments everyone
click here for my other Ant-Man and the Wasp
quantumania trailer video with different footage
and click here for my new Deadpool 3 in Wolverine
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!